OKAY -- SO WE HAVE A QUORUM
RIGHT.
NOW WE ONLY HAVE ONE MORE FOR
YOU CAN SERVICES OKAY. TWENTY TO
GIVE ALL THEY WANT TO DO THAT
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I AM CALLING -- THIS HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION TO ORDER
AS A SUB COMMITTEE WERE TO START
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE -- THE
SERGEANTS TO PLEASE CALL THOSE
MEMBERS WHO HAVE.
SIGNED UP TO RESENT THEIR BILLS
SO THEY CAN SHOW UP AND PRESENT
THEIR BILLS THAT WOULD BE GREAT --
AGAIN WE'LL START IS
SUBCOMMITTEE WE HAVE THIRTEEN
BILLS IN THE CHEN TODAY
INCLUDING FIVE ON CONSENT.
BY THE MEASURES ON CONSENT ARE
AS FOLLOWS.
ACR THIRTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
SB.
WATER -- EIGHTY SEVEN OKAY A MAN --
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT IS YOUR EIGHTY
SEVEN WITH THE MOMENTS SB
THIRTEEN WHEN I SB.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT SB THREE FORTY
SIX SB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT S. C.
R. SIX THOSE ARE ALL -- ON
CONSENT.
AND WITH THAT WE ARE READY GREEN
IN WITH THE FIRST AUTHORED ON C.
AUTHOR HERE IF YOU'RE LISTENING
THIS HEARING IF YOU'RE AUTHORS
WANT THEIR BILL IF YOUR THE
OTHERS WANT THEIR BILLS HEARD
THEY WILL HEAD DOWN HERE --
QUICKLY BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
WAITING FOR EVER.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR DOCTOR PAN --
SENATOR HILL.
CENTER HERTZBERG CENTER BATES.
AND RUBIO.
CENTER I'M BURKE.
AND ROTH MAKE YOUR WAY DOWN HERE
WE ARE NOT WAITING FOREVER
.
NOT TO ME THAT ALL SENATORS ARE
LIVE BUT ANYWAYS -- SO WE DON'T
HAVE FORM IT -- I'VE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG IS PRESENTING
FILE ITEM NUMBER -- CHIEF FOR
FILING -- FOR AND IT'S SP TWO
SIX FIVE A FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU.
NUMBER.
I WAS LAST YEAR [inaudible]
LAST YEAR WE ARE USUALLY THEY'LL.
TWO OF WHICH I THINK POLICY
HEADED FOR BIPARTISAN BASIS
[inaudible]
AND YOUR MERRY ON PRACTICE WAS
SHAKING.
WHAT'S ONE J. [inaudible]
IF -- STUDENT HAS.
DONE -- OVERALL HAVE A LIFE.
RENTS HAVE INDICATED THAT NO WE
HAVE SEEN EXAMPLES OF OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT LITERALLY REALLY
CAN'T GET CERTAIN ONE FOUR OUT
FROM UNDER CONTRACT.
SOMETIMES YOU GET A FOUR HOURS
OF USE THAT. FIVE THE WEATHER IS
A FINANCIAL ISSUE [inaudible]
THERE'S A IN FRONT OF ALL THEIR
OWN.
WHEN I WAS IN CLASS THIS WILL
PROBABLY NOT APPROVAL HERE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY CORONER'S
[inaudible]
RIGHT DOES IT GETS IT RIGHT
NUMBER OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS OR
PROBLEM.
MAY YOUR ATTENTION AND SO --
ROLES IN THE SAME HARSH --
SWITCHBOARD.
SO FAR OKAY -- MARBLES --
SPONSOR RESERVES FRAZIER.
YEAH LAWMAKERS WORK SHE USED TO
WORK AT AND ONCE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE OTHER PARTY.
THERE YOU GO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I REPEAT EVERYTHING
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THE THIRTY
TWO MILLION PEOPLE WATCHING THIS
HEARING HEARD ME.
THERE'S A REASON WE DID THAT AND
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTIES.
WE FOUND THAT CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES WERE BEING FED
BLENDED HALF OF CHEESE
SANDWICHES -- THE THINGS WE
FOUND HERE IN CALIFORNIA -- WERE
POOR AND REALLY -- WE ARE WE'RE
SO GRATEFUL TO LIVE IN A STATE
WHERE WHEN PEOPLE HEARD ABOUT
THAT THEY CHANGE THE POLICIES
LOS ANGELES COUNTY SAID WE ARE
WE'RE EMBARRASSED WE WON'T DO
THAT ANYMORE.
THE AT THE BOARD OF OF THE
CITRUS HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT ALSO
DECIDED TO VOLUNTARILY NOT DO IT --
BUT BUT WE PASSED THE BILL AND I
WE FOUND THE UNFORTUNATELY THERE
ARE STILL SOME CONFUSION SOME --
THINGS IN THE BILL THAT WE COULD
MAKE STRONGER -- TO MAKE THE
CASE THAT A CHILD CANNOT BE
SHAMED.
IF THEIR PARENTS OWES DEBT
REMEMBER THAT WE DON'T -- THE
THE DEBT IS NOT -- TO THE CHILD
THE DEBT IS OWED TO THE PARENT
AT THE THE PARENT -- SAID THAT --
NOT THE CHILD -- AND USING
CHILDREN AT TO COLLECT ON A DEBT.
IS -- IS NOT.
IT IS NOT HELPFUL FOR AN
EDUCATIONAL SETTING IT DOESN'T
IMPROVE THE NUTRITION OF THE
CHILD AND IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY.
RESULT IN THE DEATH BEEN
COLLECTED.
ON SO THIS BILL BASICALLY TAKES
US TO THE NEXT STEP IT CLARIFIES --
THE UNDER NO CIRCUMSTANCE CAN A
CHILD BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY
BECAUSE OF THE DEBT.
OWED AS A RESULT OF A SCHOOL
LUNCH EATEN -- AND THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE OFFERED DIFFERENT
FOOD AS WELL -- WITH THEIR
EXPERIENCE AT THE LUNCH COUNTER
SHOULDN'T BE DIFFERENT THAN A
CHILD WHOSE PARENTS DON'T --
DEBT OF WE'RE REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE CLOSE READ BY THE
COMMITTEE -- STAFF AND THE AND
THE AMENDMENTS AND WE DO THINK
THAT MAKES IT STRONGER -- WE
ARCHER I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- CENTERS YOU WANT TO
PUT A COMMENT ON THE RECORD
SINCE WE WERE.
SILENT WHEN I KNOW MY PRESS
DIVISION WE COULD HEAR A SINGLE
THING YOU SAID.
KATIE NOW SHE JUST HEARD IT NO I
I THINK WE'RE OKAY I JUST.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AND
YOU KNOW I I THINK THAT -- THE
WESTERN CENTER MADE THE POINT
WELL IT WILL TAKE IN THE STORIES
ARE EXTRAORDINARY THE IMPACT A
CRITICAL THE NEED -- MORAL IN
ITS TONE AND SO I ASK YOUR
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE I THANK
YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
WE'RE PROUD TO CO SPONSOR ON
BEHALF OF OUR CAFETERIA WORKERS
THAT STRUCK WITH FOOD AND
SECURITY THEMSELVES TO HAVE TIM
FORCES POLICIES ARE PREVENTABLE
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS AND
NATIONAL THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU THEY GO.
I HAD A CONTRACT OUT ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DONNA ARE TO GIVE WHICH
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN SUPPORT --
ANY ANY FURTHER SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE ORIGINALLY
HAD AN OPPOSE UNLESS I'M IN A
POSITION WE APPRECIATE THE AYE
WORKING WITH AUTHORS OFFICE AND
A TO ADDRESS MOST OF THOSE
CONCERNS ONLY CONCERN WE HAVE
LEFT IS REALLY ON THE FISCAL END.
WITH SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIMB Là
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIMITED ABILITY
TO RECOUP THE NON REIMBURSABLE
MEALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S A GOOD POINT --
WITH THAT I SEE NO FOR THEIR
OPPOSITION WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE THEM
WELL WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET
SO WE'LL WAIT UNTIL SUCH TIME AS
WE DO.
HAVE A QUORUM -- ANY QUESTIONS
READY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE QUICK COMMENT I'D LIKE TO
THINK I'M THE SPONSOR AND THE
AUTHOR MY OVERLAPPING SENATOR
FROM SAN FERNANDO VALLEY -- AS
WE MOVE FURTHER AND FURTHER INTO
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPORTANCE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF
THE CHILDREN OF HAVING THE
EMOTIONAL TRAUMA ASPECT
PARTICULARLY RELATED ISSUES OF
POVERTY BE A PART OF EVERY
SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT NOW IN A
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENT THIS IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT PIECE OF THAT --
WE KNOW HOW MANY OF OUR CHILDREN
STRUGGLE WITH FOOD AND SECURITY
AND SO I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS MEASURE I DO THINK ON THE
POINTS RAISED BY -- OUR SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICERS ARE IMPORTANT
BUT I THINK WE LOOK AT THAT FROM
A BUDGETARY PERSPECTIVE PERHAPS
IN THE UPCOMING CYCLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I USED AS
CHAIRMAN.
JUST ADVISE THE PRINT A FEDERAL
BILL IS IS BEEN INTRODUCED TO TO
TRY TO TAKE CARE OF THAT FISCAL
ASPECT.
INVOLVING MEMBERS MEANT FOR
SCHOOL MEALS.
IT'S IT'S IN PROCESS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
OUR OR WAITING.
ALL RIGHT -- WITH THAT I SEE NO
FURTHER COMMENT FROM THE
COMMITTEE -- WILL WAIT TO HAVE A
CORPSMAN TO SUCH A TIME AS WE
ACCEPT A MOTION THANK THANK YOU
SENATOR.
THANK YOU KNOW WILL MOVE TO
SENATOR PAN. TO RAISE DOWN HERE
FROM HIS OWN COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
A YEAR IT'S A FILE NUMBER EIGHT
IT'S AB OR SB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'M PLEASED TO OFFER SO I WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH MY STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AS WE
AGREED UPON.
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA IS IN THE
MIDST OF THE YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS -- DEPRESSION SYMPTOMS AT
ALL TIME HIGH FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ACCORDING TO THE US
DEPARTMENT HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES NEARLY ONE IN THREE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
SURVEYED REPORTED FEELING.
SADDER HOPELESS ALMOST EVERY DAY
FOR TWO OR MORE WEEKS IN A ROW
THINK ABOUT THAT.
AND NEARLY ONE IN FIVE A
REPORTED IT'S USUALLY CONSIDERED
ATTEMPTING SUICIDE.
TEACHERS AND SCHOOL STAFF ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF THESE CRISES
AND AS SUCH SHOULD BE TRAINED TO
IDENTIFY AND HELP STUDENTS WHO
ARE SUFFERING.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THE SOONER
PEOPLE GET HELP FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
CONCERNS THE MORE LIKELY THEY
ARE TO HAVE POSITIVE OUTCOMES.
AS AMENDED SB FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT EDUCATION DOING THAT
IF I AND ACTUALLY RECOGNIZED
EVIDENCE BASED TRAINING PROGRAM
ON YOUTH MENTAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO TRAIN.
CLASSIFIED AND CERTIFIED STAFF.
SUBJECT TO APPROPRIATION CD
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO DISSEMINATE
SELECT THE TRAINING PROGRAM TO
ELEAZAR AT NO COST.
FURTHER ALL ELEAZAR BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE WOULD BE REQUIRED
TO CERTIFY TO CD E. THAT LEAST
10% OF CLASSIFIED AND 10% OF
CERTIFIED STAFF THAT HAVE DIRECT
CONTACT WITH STUDENTS OR TO
CLASSIFY STAFFORD INTO CERTIFIED
STAFF WHICHEVER IS GREATER HAVE
ATTAINED THE TRAINING.
TRAINING IS NEED TO INCREASE
SCHOOL INTO ME LEVEL CAPACITY
IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS MENTAL
HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE IT
ISSUES AMONG YOUTH.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY
COALITION BEHAVIOR HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS MENTAL HEALTH
ADVOCATES INCLUDING CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES THE CALIFORNIA
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION CHILDREN'S NOW AND
LADY GAGA'S BORN THIS WAY
FOUNDATION.
BEFORE I BRING IT OVER TO
WITNESSES THOUGH I WANT TO
PARTICULARLY EMPHASIZE THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT OUR TEACHERS ARE --
SCHOOL STAFF ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES AND WE WANT TO GIVE THE
TOOLS AND THEN A FIVE BUT I ALSO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE ALSO
NEED TO PROVIDE THEM -- THE TRUE
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT THEY NEED
THIS IS JUST WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IDENTIFICATION FRONTLINE
PROVIDING SOME INITIAL --
INTERVENTION BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU NEXT RECOGNIZE THE CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR YOUR WORK CAN
BE SURE WE GET THE RESOURCES FOR
THINGS LIKE MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
STAFF AND SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT YOU'VE PROPOSED.
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN TRYING TO BE
SURE WE DO THAT WE CAN TAP AND
OTHER SORTS OF FUNNY BECAUSE WE
CAN HAVE THE TEACHERS AND STAFF
AND THEN A FIND HELP DO
SOMETHING BUT WE DEEM WE HAVE
THE END OF THE NEEDS BILL PASSED.
ON TO GETTING THAT THE THE FULL
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT THE
STUDENTS THE SERVER SO -- WITH
THAT.
THIS IS AN ESSENTIAL COMPONENT
TO MAKING THIS WORK I HAVE
WITNESSES WITH ME I'VE ANDREAS
MMN FROM WELLNESS TOGETHER AND
RAINY HANDLE FROM THE TRI CITY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH JUST TO
CLARIFY YOU DO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS YES.
THE COURSE.
QUITE A OUT YOUR WITNESSES MAY
PROCEED TO MESSAGE PLEASE.
KAY THANK YOU CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS ANDREAS ZIMMERMAN AND
I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT I HAVE HAD A
CAREER WORKING IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS AS A HIGH SCHOOL SCIENCE
TEACHER AND ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL
AND TRAINER OF NEW TEACHERS --
I'VE EXPERIENCED OUR STATE'S
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM FROM ALL
THREE OF THESE VANTAGE POINTS
AND I CAN UNEQUIVOCALLY SAY.
THAT THERE IS A HUGE NEED FOR
MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID TRAINING
IN OUR SECONDARY EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
WHEN I RETIRED LAST YEAR I
WANTED TO HELP ADDRESS THAT NEED
AND SO I BECAME A MENTAL HEALTH
FIRST AID INSTRUCTOR WITH
WELLNESS TOGETHER AND NONPROFIT
AGENCY DELIVERING VITAL?
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
STUDENTS FAMILIES TEACHERS AND
ADMINISTRATORS THROUGOUT
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK ABOUT ALL THE MIST STEPS
I COULD HAVE AVOIDED AS A
TEACHER AND ADMINISTRATOR IF I
HAD HAD THE MENTAL HEALTH FIRST
AID TRAINING AT THE BEGINNING OF
MY CAREER.
AND THE IMPACT THAT WOULD HAVE
MULTIPLIED ACROSS ALL TEACHERS
AND SCHOOLS.
ARE YOUTH DESERVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE THEY'RE
SURROUNDED BY ADULTS WHO ARE
TRAINED TO RESPOND TO THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS.
TRAINING 10% OF TEACHERS AND
SCHOOL PERSONNEL IS A GOOD START
BUT TO EVEN COME CLOSE TO
ADDRESSING THE SCALE OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS IN OUR
SCHOOLS WE NEED TO BE TRAINING
ALL TEACHERS.
IN THE SIMPLE YET LIFE CHANGING
SKILLS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
HI N..
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS REMAIN HURDLE
AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF IMAGES
SAY AT TRI CITY MENTAL HEALTH.
AND AS THE MENTAL HEALTH
AUTHORITY OF FOR SERVICE AREA WE
KNOW THE IMPACT MENTAL HEALTH
SHOUT CHALLENGES HAVE ON A
COMMUNITY.
AND OUT MANY EDUCATORS ARE THE
FIRST TO SEE EXPERIENCE AND
RESPOND TO A STUDENT OR A CHILD
IN CRISIS THAT ARE NOT FULLY
PREPARED TO PROVIDE THE CARE AND
SUPPORT THEY NEED. TO INCREASE
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY CAPACITY
TRI CITY HAS PROVIDED OVER FORTY
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH FOR STATE
TRAININGS TO OVER.
SIX HUNDRED MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY AND OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS SINCE PROVIDING THESE
TRAINEES WE'VE TRAININGS WE'VE
HAD POSITIVE FEEDBACK FROM
PARTICIPANTS SOME EXAMPLES ARE.
I WILL DEFINITELY TAKE WHAT I
HAVE LEARNT TODAY TO BETTER
SUPPORT MY STUDENTS I HAD NO
IDEA THAT MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES STARTED SO EARLY IN
CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
IT MAKES ME RETHINK HOW I
SUPPORT MY KIDS AND STUDENTS.
MENTAL HEALTH WAS NOT DISCUSSED
OR AS A TOPIC WHILE GOING TO
SCHOOL I WISH I HAD THIS
INFORMATION EARLIER IN MY CAREER
TO BETTER SUPPORT MY STUDENTS.
AND AS A PARENT I KNEW MY CHILD
WAS STRUGGLING I WANTED TO HELP
HIM BUT DID NOT KNOW WHAT TO DO
I WISH I HAD THIS TRAINING
SOONER SO I COULD SUPPORT MY
CHILD.
OTHER WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
OUTREACH AND TRAINING SO WE KNOW
THAT WE NEED TO DO MORE.
OUR CHILDREN ARE SUFFERING EVERY
DAY AND PARENTS CAREGIVERS AND
EDUCATORS DON'T HAVE THE
INFORMATION RESOURCES ARE TOOLS
TO WRITE THE SUPPORT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE AND
SPONSORS FOR YOUR DILIGENT WORK
ON THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU UP COULD WE JUST STOP
FOR ONE MINUTE HAVE THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL HERE KILEY KILEY HERE
KALRA.
KALRA HERE MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH HERE VOEPEL [inaudible]
WEBER.
THANK YOU IT JUST SOLVE SO SOME
OF THOSE OTHER KNOWN I HAVE
MISTER HILL NEXT.
SENATOR BATES RUBIO AND THEN
SENATOR ALAN.
THE ORDER I HAVE.
YOU MAY PROCEED -- I'M SORRY
WE'RE GOING O GO TO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OTHERS IN SUPPORT MAY
COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE STATE
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY PLEASE.
WE HONOR HER CURVY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES LEAD
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
ROB L<c.cyan>G WITH THE COUNTY</c>
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION A SPONSOR AND IN THE
SPORT.
DEBORAH BROWN WITH CHILDREN ALSO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR TERROR MEMBERS
RON RAP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW WITH CATHOLIC CHURCH
IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
SIR QUICKLY DOES THIS BILL
PERTAIN. TO TO TO PRIVATE
SCHOOLS.
NO NO IT'S PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT THANK YOU
GOOD.
RENDON MARGIE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
DON ARE TO GET **** CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
I THANK YOU.
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
FEATURE ALL SWEATSHOP AT THE
ANAHEIM UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT -- I APOLOGIZE WE HAD A
LATE OPPOSE UNLESS AMEND WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING ON THIS AND DOCTOR PAN
FOR ACCEPTING AMENDMENT SO WE
YEAH.
REMOVE OPPOSITION.
GREAT THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
OPPOSITION COME FORWARD.
SEEING NO FURTHER OPPOSITION.
IF YOU'RE POSE GET UP HERE.
I'M SORRY I'M LATE DANNY OFFER
FOR PLATINUM VISORS REPRESENTING
THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS NAMI CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE WITH THAT -- OVER YOU BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE I'LL JUST MAKE%
A COMMENT HERE DOCTOR PAN
APPRECIATE APPROACH WILL MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT CREATING
ANOTHER CREDENTIAL.
I KNOW THAT'S NOT YOUR INTENT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE NOT
CREATING A PATH. FOR FOR FOR
TEACHERS TO DIAGNOSE.
AND OR TREAT MENTAL ILLNESS
INSIDE OR OUTSIDE THE CLASSROOM
BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT'S PROBABLY.
NOT NOT NOT THE BEST APPROACH.
OUR LITTLE CONCERN ABOUT THE
TIME ALLOTTED TO THIS -- BUT
EITHER WAY YOU KNOW I'M I'M
SUPPORT TODAY FOR SURE.
AND I APPRECIATE -- YOU KNOW
YOUR DESIRE TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE INSIDE THE SCHOOL SETTING
YES IS A CLASSROOM TEACHER I
FACED.
AND PROBABLY AND I SEE THE
BIGGEST THING WE NEED RIGHT NOW
IS PROTOCOLS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN I
THINK BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW I'M
NOT AN EXPERT.
I THINK A STUDENT MIGHT HAVE
SOME ISSUES THAT AT LEAST NEED
TO BE DISCUSSED WITH SOMEONE WHO
IS A PROFESSIONAL OTHER THAN I
IN THOSE PROTOCOLS ARE SO
IMPORTANT.
AND AND AFTER IF NOT BEFORE THAT
OUR RESOURCES RIDE ONCE WE KNOW
OR EVEN WANT TO FIND OUT -- HELP
WITH STUDENTS WHERE ARE THOSE
RESOURCES AND I KNOW YOU SHARE
THAT CONCERN SO THANK YOU.
ARE THERE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WISH TO COMMENT.
A SINGLE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
WISHING TO COMMENT -- CAN WE GET
A MOTION IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED BUT MOVED A SECOND
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
HELP YOU MAKE CLOTHES. FOR SO I
WANNA THANK YOU IT TEARS ON A
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH AND SCHOOLS --
SOMEONE WHO USED TO BE A SCHOOL
PHYSICIAN I'VE WORKED WITH
TEACHERS COUNSELORS SCHOOL
NURSES ON MADE HIS ISSUES THIS
CAN BE VERY IMPORTANT I GET
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
I WITH THAT -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO HEALTH COMMITTEE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
EARLY AYE KALRA.
OUR EYES MCCARTY SMITH SMITH I
VOEPEL. ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE NUMBER EIGHT NUMBER EIGHT
YOU'RE RIGHT.
GO AHEAD MY FAULT BECAUSE VOEPEL
I'D.
WEBER.
WELL AS BY VOTERS OUT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE NOT
GOING TO PROCEED TO THE FINAL
NUMBER HREE THIS IS FILE IN OUR
THREE SB TWO TO THREE BY MR HELD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HìNH
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON SB. TWO
TO THREE IS A REPEAT OF SB
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN WHICH PASSED
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE LAST
SESSION IT WILL HELP STUDENTS
WITH SEVERE MEDICAL DISABILITIES
ATTEND SCHOOL.
THE ONLY MEDICATION THAT WORKS
FOR SOME OF THE STUDENTS AND IS
MEDICAL CANNABIS.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW A PARENT OR
GUARDIAN TO COME ON CAMPUS TO
ADMINISTER MEDICAL CANNABIS TO
THEM IN NON SMOKING AND NON
VAPING FORMS.
MANY OF THE STUDENTS NEED TO
TAKE A DOSE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS
AT REGULAR INTERVALS WHICH OFTEN
INCLUDES DURING SCHOOL HOURS
CURRENT LAW DOES NOT ALLOW ANY
FORM OF CANNABIS ON SCHOOL
GROUNDS.
THE STUDENTS MUST BE PICKED UP
BY THEIR PARENTS AND TAKEN OFF
CAMPUS.
IN BY LAW THOUSAND FEET OFF OF
CAMPUS IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THEIR
MEDICINE WHICH IS VERY
DISRUPTIVE TO THEIR LEARNING.
SB TWO TWENTY THREE WILL ALLOW
THE GOVERNING BOARD OF K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOL DISTRICT
COUNTY BOARD OF EDUCATION OR
CHARTER SCHOOL. TO CHOOSE
WHETHER TO ADOPT THIS POLICY IS
NOT A STATE MANDATE.
DISTRICTS AND COUNTIES THAT OPT
IN CAN OPT OUT AT ANY TIME FOR
ANY REASON.
INCLUDING IF FEDERAL FUNDING IS
PUT AT RISK AS A RESULT OF THAT
POLICY IN THIS POLICY.
SB TWO TWENTY THREE REQUIRES THE
STUDENT TO BE QUALIFIED.
A QUALIFIED MEDICAL CANNABIS
PATIENT WITH A DOCTOR'S
RECOMMENDATION TYPICALLY THE
MEDICINE IS ADMINISTERED AS OIL
CAPSULES TEACHERS LIQUIDS OR
TOPICAL CREAMS.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES THAT A
PARENT MUST ONE GIVE THE SCHOOL
A COPY OF THEIR CHILD'S MEDICAL
CANNABIS RECOMMENDATION TO KEEP
ON FILE.
SIGN IN WHEN THEY COME ON CAMPUS
NOT DISRUPT THE EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT AND TAKE ALL
CANNABIS FROM SCHOOL GROUNDS
AFTER ADMINISTRATION.
WASHINGTON COLORADO FLORIDA
MAINE AND NEW JERSEY HAVE ALL
PASSED LEGISLATION ALLOWING
STUDENTS TO USE MEDICAL CANNABIS
ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES SB TWO TWENTY
THREE IS A FIRST STEP.
TOWARD ENSURING THAT STUDENTS
WITH SEVERE MEDICAL DISABILITIES
HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO A
QUALITY PUBLIC EDUCATION AS
THEIR PEERS I DO HAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- OF YOUR
WITNESSES MAY PROCEED TWO
MINUTES EACH PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME
IS KARENA MCKAY AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT JUDGE SHOWS ACT AS P..
TWO TO THREE MY SON GIOVANNI JO
JO JIMENEZ HAS USED DVD AND
TEACH THE FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS.
SINCE THE AGE OF THREE MONTHS
OLD HE HAS BEEN PLAGUED WITH
EPILEPSY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN HE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
LETTUCE LENNIX BECAUSE THOSE
SYNDROME.
THIS KINDA EPILEPSY IS VERY RARE
AND HARD TO CONTROL.
JO JO WAS MEDICATED WITH HIGH
DOSES OF PHARMACEUTICALS AND
ALSO FIT IT WITH THE VNS VAGUS
NERVE STIMULATOR.
ALL WITH NO SUCCESS I WAS
WATCHING MY SON DIE RIGHT BEFORE
MY EYES I KNEW THERE HAD TO BE A
BETTER WAY.
I BEGAN RESEARCHING CANNABIS AND
THE EFFECTS OF IT TO TREAT
EPILEPSY AND CHOSE TO TRY IT AS
OUR LAST RESORT.
WE HAD TO GET WRITTEN APPROVAL
FROM OUR OUR NEUROLOGISTS PRIOR
TO SEEKING A MEDICAL MARIJUANA
DOCTOR.
THAT TREATED MINERS NOT ALL DO.
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTEEN WAS THE
FIRST TIME HE TRIED CANNABIS AND
IT SEEM VERY HOPEFUL.
DAY BY DAY I SEEN THEM EMERGE.
AND START ENGAGING AGAIN
FEATURES WERE DECREASED
IMMEDIATELY.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL TO TO JO JO
NEEDING A DOES AT SCHOOL TWELVE
PM DAILY.
I FEEL CANNABIS SHOULD BE
TREATED AS EVERY OTHER
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE ON CAMPUS.
IT IS NOT FAIR THAT IT THIS
MEDICINE AS SAVE MY SON'S LIFE.
AND NOT BE GIVEN THE SAME
TREATMENT AND AND ABILITY AS
OTHER PHARMACEUTICALS ON CAMPUS.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS BILL
BECOMING LAW.
LICENSE LIFE AND SO MANY OTHERS
DEPEND ON IT.
IN FIVE THOUSAND YEARS NO ONE
HAS DIED FROM CANNABIS USE.
IT IS THE ONLY MEDICINE THAT CAN
STREET SO MANY DIFFERENT
ELEMENTS ON SUCH A WIDE SPECTRUM
FROM EPILEPSY TO ARTHRITIS TO
CANCER.
THE PARKINSON'S.
IT ALSO HAS THE ABILITY TO
REGENERATE BRAIN CELLS THIS HAVE
SEEN FIRST HAND.
I ASK YOU FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY
HEART TO GIVE A YES VOTE TODAY
AND BE THE VOICE MY SON AND SO
MANY OTHERS WOUND.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR
COMPASSION.
THANK YOU NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JENNIFER
COMMISSION I'M A WIFE A MOTHER
TO BEAUTIFUL FIVE YEAR OLD BOY
NAMED ZACHARY OR Z. AS WE CALL
HIM.
AND I'M ALSO AN ICU NURSE TO THE
LEVEL TWO TRAUMA CENTER IN SAN
JOSE.
I STILL BEFORE YOU LAST YEAR ON
BEHALF OF MY SON AND OTHERS
DIDN'T REQUIRE CANNABIS TO
CONTROL DIFFERENT ELEMENTS.
ZACHARY WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
SEIZURES AT FIVE MONTHS OLD WE
TRIED EVERYTHING THE DOCTORS
HAVE RECOMMENDED AND EVEN ON
SEVEN MEDICATIONS HE WAS STILL
HAVING FORTY TO SIXTY SEIZURES A
DAY.
THEY WERE GETTING WORSE AND
WORSE AND WE WERE TOLD EXACTLY
WOULD NEVER WALK TALK AND YOU
WOULD PROBABLY NOT MAKE IT TO
THE AGE OF FIVE THE MEDS THAT
DAY PRESCRIBE FOR HIM LEFT HIM
LIFELESS HOLLOW AND STILL
SEIZING.
MY HUSBAND SAKE A SPECIAL ABOUT
CANNABIS IN THE SUMMER OF TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN ASKED IF WE
COULD TRY IT.
I WAS COMPLETELY AGAINST IT AND
THOUGHT HE WAS CRAZY.
TURNER COLLEGES THAT THERE IS
NOTHING REALLY LEFT TO DO AND SO
TO GO AHEAD AND GIVE IT A TRY.
WHEN WE STARTED IT TOOK A COUPLE
OF WEEKS BUT WITH IN ABOUT TWO
WEEKS WE SAW THERE WERE NO
SEIZURES LEFT IN HIS EEGS OUR
BRAIN WAVE PATTERNS STARTED
IMPROVING?
PRETTY QUICKLY THEREAFTER.
HE'S NOW IN KINDERGARTEN HE JUST
FINISHED HIS FIRST YEAR OF
KINDERGARTEN -- THAT KID WHO
SAID THEY WERE HE WOULD NEVER
WALK OR TALK IS LEARNING TO
WRITE HE CAN SPELL HIS NAME.
HE'S SPEAKING.
BUT THE MEDICATION THAT SAVED
HIM THAT IS NOT ALLOW HIM TO DO
ALL THESE THINGS.
IS NOW FORCING HIM OUT OFTHE
CLASSROOM BECAUSE OF OUTDATED
INFORMATION -- THIS YEAR YOU HAD
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS OF
SCHOOL.
EVERY DAY WE GO TO SCHOOL TO
PULL HIM OUT OF CLASS WALKING A
THOUSAND FEET OFF CAMPUS AND
GIVE HIM HIS MEDICATION AND
BRING HIM BACK TO SCHOOL.
DICKS IS ABOUT THIRTY MINUTES ON
A GOOD DAY.
THAT TIME IS 10% OF HIS TOTAL
SCHOOL DAY AND IS EQUAL TO FIVE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED MINUTES OR
NINETY HOURS OF SCHOOL TIME.
THAT WAS JUST HIS KINDERGARTEN
YEAR BY THE TIME YOU GRADUATE
HIGH SCHOOL HE WILL LOSE ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THREE AND A HALF HOURS OF SCHOOL.
OR SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND TEN MINUTES OF
EDUCATION TIME.
WHAT ELSE COULD HE HAVE LEARNED
DURING THAT TIME?
I THINK HE WOULD PROBABLY BE
ABLE TO WRITE THE WHOLE ALPHABET
NOT JUST HIS NAME.
I HAVEN'T EVEN ADDRESSED THE
OTHER TWELVE KIDS IN HIS CLASS
THROUGH DISRUPTED WHEN WE COME
TO PULL HIM OUT OF CLASS.
WE ARE BEING FORCED TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN HIS MEDICAL NEEDS AND
HIS EDUCATION AS WELL AS HIS
CLASSMATES EDUCATION.
THIS IS UNCONSCIONABLE AND MUST
BE CHANGED.
PLEASE VOTE YES ON SB TWO TO
THREE JUDGES ACT I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY ONE DID VOTE VERY
WELL DONE BOTH OF YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
ERICA HOFFMAN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
FOR THE EDUCATIONAL NEEDS OF THE
STUDENTS AND ENSURING THAT THEY
DO RECEIVE.
A FAIR AND APPROPRIATE EDUCATION
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
UNDER SO LEASE ON BEHALF OF
UNITED KIND OF THIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NO OPPOSITION.
WILL BRING IT BACK ANY QUESTIONS
FOR MANY THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
JUST A COMMENT I'M I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOUR WITNESSES AM VERY
OFTEN AS MOTHERS SOME OF THE
MOST FIERCE WORK WE DO IS ON
BEHALF OF OUR OWN CHILDREN BUT
THAT ADVOCACY EXTENDS TO THE
BENEFIT AND WELL BEING OF OTHER
CHILDREN AS WELL SO I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
AND YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER COMMENT
FROM ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY -- SENATOR YOU MAY
CLOSE IF WE ASK FOR A VOTE
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU IN
COLLEGE WE HAVE A MOTION.
REMOVED AND A SECOND -- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST TWO YEARS
SHERRY COMMITTEE.
O'DONNELL HI O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO KALRA MCCARTY SMITH
SMITH I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO WEBER.
IN THE BILL US. TWO TWO RIGHT
NOW SO IF YOU WERE VOTE AND IT
WILL BE OUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK CAL EXCRETION THANK
YOU CENTER THANK YOU DEAR
WITNESSES FOR THANK YOU FOR
ADVOCATING FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
THANK YOU THREE TIMES -- NEXT
WAS CENTER BATES HERE I DON'T
SEE SENATOR BATES -- I SEE
SENATOR ALLEN WAS HE SENATOR
RUBIO NO CENTER ALLEN'S YOU.
RAVAGER QUICK THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A FILE ITEM.
TWELVE SB.
ONE SIX SB SIX EIGHTY SIX FILE
ITEM.
TWELVE YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY.
HI THANK YOU SO MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. FOR SAW IT ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE WORK ON THIS
BILL.
AND FOR THE DETAILED ANALYSIS
THIS IS A BILL THAT IMPLEMENTS --
BASE ESTABLISHES A PROGRAM
IMPLEMENT COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS TO IMPROVE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES LIVING IN SOME OF
CALIFORNIA'S.
MOST DISTRESSED NEIGHBORHOODS.
HOW WE KNOW THAT GOD THAT THE
CHILDREN LIVING IN THESE
COMMUNITIES LACK ACCESS TO
ADEQUATE HEALTH ACADEMIC AND
SOCIAL PREPARATION -- OPTIONS
THAT ARE NEEDED TO ACHIEVE
SUCCESS NOW WE KNOW THAT.
SOMETHING LIKE 70% OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN LIVING
COMMUNITIES ACROSS STREET
POVERTY.
THAT'S NEARLY TWO MILLION
CHILDREN LIVING IN POVERTY.
AND WE KNOW THAT IT TAKES A
HOLISTIC SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS
THE IN THE IMPLICATIONS AND
APPLICATIONS OF POVERTY --
FAMILIES NEED INNOVATIVE AND
PRACTICAL APPROACHES TO HELP
THEIR PROBLEMS AND SO I TO
TWENTY TEN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION I STARTED TO WORK
ON THIS ISSUE THE ESTABLISH THE
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD PROGRAM. TO
TRANSFORM SCHOOLS NEIGHBORHOODS
IN -- INTO MINORITIES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY THROUGH A ROBUST
SYSTEM OF COMMUNITY SUPPORT A
HOLISTIC APPROACH -- BY WHICH
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE INVOLVED IN
THEIR CHILDREN'S ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE AND PROVIDING THEM
WITH QUALITY SOCIAL AND
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES.
I IN CALIFORNIA ONLY -- WE HAD
FIVE ESTABLISH AN OPERATING
PROMISED NEIGHBORHOODS --
SERVING MORE THAN THIRTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
ANNUALLY -- THESE NEIGHBORHOODS
WORK TO ENSURE THAT ALL THE
CHILDREN GROWING UP IN -- IN IN
THESE ZONES HAVE ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY EARLY CHILDHOOD PROGRAMS
SCHOOLS HEALTH SERVICES SOCIAL
SERVICES RELIABLE SYSTEMS OF
FAMILY COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
THAT WILL PREPARE THEM TO ATTAIN
AN EXCELLENT EDUCATION.
AND SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION TO
COLLEGE AND CAREERS IN THE WHOLE
IDEA IS IS THAT ALL THESE
DIFFERENT -- SUPPORTS ARE
INTEGRATED AND WORKING TOGETHER.
AND THERE'S A KIND OF A HOLISTIC
APPROACH -- TO ENSURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOODS VARIOUS METRICS
ARE USED TO TRACK OUTCOMES THAT
AND INCLUDING KINDERGARTEN
READINESS PROFICIENCY IN CORE.
K. THROUGH TWELVE SUBJECTS
FAMILY ECONOMIC RESILIENCE IN
SUPPORT FOR THE CHILD BECAUSE WE
NEED TO GIVE.
FAMILIES A SUPPORTIVE TO LEARN
AND KNOW HOW TO HOW TO RAISE A
KID AS A PROUD FATHER OF AN
EIGHT MONTH OLD VERY FIRST TIME
I'M I'M GETTING A CRASH COURSE
IN -- AND ALL THE CHALLENGES OF
OF OF OF PARENTAL PREP -- AND
THEN OF COURSE YOU KNOW WILL
ALSO NEED TO PROVIDE FAMILIES
WITH THE INFORMATION THEY NEED.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR KIDS
HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTHY LIVING --
THERE'S BEEN GREAT TRACK RECORD
OF EFFECTIVE AND ENCOURAGING
OUTCOMES FROM OUR PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS BOTH AROUND THE
NATION IN THE STATE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIA HE
WERE HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
RATES IN THAT ZONE OF SEPTEMBER
WE HAVE RISEN.
BY 15% OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS --
I KNOW THAT IN IN IN SAN
FRANCISCO'S PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD
THIS AN EXTRAORDINARY GRADUATION
RATES INCREASES AMONGST THE
AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY --
THEIR GRADUATION RATES IN THE
AFTERMATH COMMUNITY IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO PROMISE ON ROSE FROM
46293% SINCE THE IMPLICATION OF
THE PROGRAM WHICH IS.
PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY -- I NOW
WEIGH PARTICIPATING HIGH SCHOOLS
IN THE PROGRAM HAVE MORE THAN
DOUBLE THE PERCENT OF STUDENTS
WHO GRADUATE COLLEGE READY.
SO THIS BILL CREATES A PROGRAM --
TO BE MINISTER BY THE CALIFORNIA
PART OF EDUCATION. TO AWARD
GRANTS TO UP TO TWENTY PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOODS AROUND THE STATE
TO IMPLEMENT -- PLACE BASED
CONTINUUM OF CRADLE TO COLLEGE
AND CAREER SOLUTIONS IN TARGETED
HIGH NEED NEIGHBORHOODS -- THE
PROGRAM INTENDS TO IMPROVE
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT COLLEGE
SUCCESS CAREER READY MISS AND
BUILD STRONG FAMILY.
AND COMMUNITY SUPPORT SO I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY DIXON SUNDERLAND --
USE FROM THE YOUTH POLICY
INSTITUTE AND RICHARD WRIGHT
FROM CALIFORNIA PROMISED
NEIGHBOR NETWORK AND THEY'RE
HERE TO TESTIFY IN IN SUPPORT OF
THE YOUR WITNESSES MAY PROCEED
TO MESSAGE PLEASE.
I SAW -- DIXON SLINGERLAND WITH --
THE YOUTH POLICY INSTITUTE -- IN
LOS ANGELES THE LOS ANGELES
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD AS WELL AS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PROMISED NEIGHBORHOOD NETWORK
MANY FOLKS IN THE ROOM.
FROM THE FIVE PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT SENATOR ALLEN
MENTIONED -- I JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THE REMARKABLE RESULTS
THAT ARE BEING ACHIEVED IN SOME
OF THE MOST.
SOME OF THE DENSEST HIGHEST
POVERTY MOST IS IS MANAGED
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA -- THE
POTENTIAL IS ENORMOUS TO
REPLICATE AND EXPAND THIS MODEL
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT NOW IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER SIX YEARS.
AS MENTIONED PRESIDENT OBAMA
ESTABLISHES A SIGNATURE
INITIATIVE ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO
AND FIRST COMING INTO OFFICE.
SO WE KNOW WORKS WE KNOW
CALIFORNIA CAN DO IT WELL AND
THIS IS AND THE LIFTING CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES TASK FORCE
IDENTIFIED PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD
IS ONE OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
TO EXPAND THE TWENTY LOCATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE AND THAT'S WHAT
SB -- SIX EIGHTY SIX WOULD
ACCOMPLISH SO I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
RICHARD PRYOR I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF MISSION PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THE MISSION DISTRICT DISTRICT IS
A TRADITIONALLY WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITY IN SAN FRANCISCO.
OVER THE LAST DECADE WE'VE SEEN
EIGHT THOUSAND WORKING CLASS LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS DISPLACED FROM
THE COMMUNITY.
RENT FOR A TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT
HAS RISEN TO FORTY FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS PER MONTH.
CAUSING MANY FAMILIES TO TRIPLE
UP IN OVERCROWDED APARTMENTS AND
FOR SOME DISPLAY STUDENTS. TO
COMMUTE FROM CITIES ACROSS THE
BAY.
THESE AND OTHER CHALLENGES HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO LOW ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE. SIX YEARS AGO OUR
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD BEGAN TO
WORK WITH MORE THAN TWENTY
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE WRAPAROUND SUPPORTS TO
STUDENTS FROM CRADLE TO COLLEGE.
AND TO CONNECT THEIR FAMILIES TO
SUPPORT AS WELL.
THE SCALE OF THE SOLUTION BEGAN
TO MATCH THE SCALE OF THE
PROBLEM.
WE WORK WITH NINE SCHOOLS AND
THREE PRESCHOOLS REACHING ALMOST
EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS AFTER
SIX YEARS.
WE SAW GRADUATION RATES INCREASE
FOR THE LATINO POPULATION.
FROM 63% 288%.
AND PRESCHOOL ASSESSMENT SCORES
JUMP FROM 24% 88%.
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS
BREAKTHROUGH SILOS AND
COORDINATE SERVICES.
PARTNER SHARE DATA AND HOLD
OURSELVES ACCOUNTABLE TO
IMPROVING RESULTS.
THROUGH RIGOROUS ANALYSIS AND
PLANNING.
THIS IS GOOD GOVERNMENT THE
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE USE OF
PUBLIC RESOURCES.
TODAY OUR PARTNER NETWORK HAS
MADE FIVE THOUSAND CONNECTIONS
FOR TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
FAMILIES HALF OF THESE
CONNECTIONS HAVE BEEN FOR
HOUSING AND FINANCIAL ASSET
BUILDING SERVICES.
BUT OTHER REFERRALS INCLUDE
MENTAL HEALTH LEGAL SERVICES AND
MORE.
EXPANDING THIS MODEL TO MORE
COMMUNITIES COULD BE
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR CALIFORNIA BY
PREPARING OUR CHILDREN. TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE ECONOMY AND BY
HELPING FAMILIES MOVE OUT OF
POVERTY.
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE THAT HAVE EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN THIS MODEL.
WITH TWENTY PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD
STRATEGICALLY LOCATED LOCATED
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THE SCALE OF
THE SOLUTION.
WOULD BEGIN TO MATCH THE SCALE
OF THE PROBLEM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GILLIAN SPENT ON WITH THE
MISSION ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY MISSION PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOOD A SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT.
PATTY CHAVEZ WITH SOUTH BAY
COMMUNITY SERVICES CHULA VISTA
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD AND SAN
DIEGO PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A SIMILAR LESS WITH SOUTH BAY
COMMUNITY SERVICES CHULA VISTA
PROBLEMS NEIGHBORHOOD IN SAN
DIEGO PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD IN
SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS TRUST BUCKLEY AND
HAVE TO SEE IF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT.
ANTHONY JACKSON STUDENT SUCCESS
COACH TENNIS IN HIGH SCHOOL THEY
WERE CALIFORNIA THEY WERE
PROMISED NEVER.
TEAM AGAIN -- STUDENT SUCCESS
COACH AT HERE HIGH SCHOOL HERE
CALIFORNIA HERE PROMISED
NEIGHBORHOOD IN SUPPORT.
I'M NOT NEARLY AREAS ASSOCIATES
IN MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPY
STAFF HERE FROM EASY TO TO FROM
THE OTHER ADDRESS THAT.
AND I AM ALSO -- MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALIST AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL -- KELLY BECAUSE WE WENT
THERE PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD I
ALSO AM A PRODUCT OF HAIR FROM
HIS NEIGHBORHOOD IN SUPPORT.
OKAY SHILOH WOULD LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT.
RACHEL CLICK IN WITH SUPPORT FOR
FAMILIES OF CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES IN SUPPORT.
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE US HERE ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY MAYOR
ERIC GARCETTI IN SUPPORT.
JACKIE ALONG WITH THE GRAYSON
SUIT AND TIE PART IN CALVET
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEXANDER CONTENT
AS A BEHALF THIS THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATED SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON KAELIN DINA FROM
POLICY LINK AS WELL AS THE
ALLIANCE FOR BOYS AND MEN OF
COLOR AND PROUD SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON NORMA GARCIA
DIRECTOR OF POLICY FOR MISSION
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AGENCY IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND SPEAKING IN
BEHALF ON BEHALF OF THE PARENTS
WHO WEREN'T ABLE TO COME TODAY
TO ASK YOU IN PERSON. FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITION WILL BRING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE SING ANY
COMMENT IS THERE ANY CONFEREE
COMMITTEE MEMBER SING ON YOU --
YOU MAY CLOSE CENTER.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL THE
FOLKS WHO CAME OUT TO EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS.
INNOVATIVE SUCCESSFUL PROVEN.
MODEL HOW WE WOULD VERY MUCH
LIKE TO SEE THIS IMPLEMENTED
HERE AND A MORE ROBUST LEVEL IN
THE CITY CALIFORNIA NAY --
RESPECT FAST REBEL.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OKAY THE WIND MOVED AND ALL
SECOND.
THIS CALL ROOM.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
AYE AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING.
KALRA.
MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NOT VOTING WEBER.
ONLY FIFTY OKAY THIS TO VOTE TO
THIS TIME.
SO START DOT COM.
ALL RIGHT RESERVED THANK YOU WE
NEED SENATOR BATES I DON'T SEE
SENATOR BATES SENATOR RUBIO.
SENATOR UMBERG.
AND I PLEASES SENATOR RON
[inaudible]
THE OUTSTANDING [inaudible]
ROB THIS [inaudible]
I'M SORRY [inaudible]
THIS REPRESENTING [inaudible]
YES
--
IF [inaudible]
AND
WE WOULD
[inaudible]
A LOT
YEAH
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
LAKE [inaudible]
SURE
[inaudible]
THIS IS
WITH THE CITY
[inaudible] FOR ME
[inaudible]
NOT JUST.
WILL NOT TAKE A FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN SENATOR UMBERG IT IS SB.
THREE NINE THREE NINE ZERO MY
CENTER OVER YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY.
AVAILABLE SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS -- WE BEGIN
BY EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND BY THANKING YOU
AND YOUR STAFF FOR IMPROVING
BILL -- SB THREE NINETY ENSURES
THAT ALL SCHOOL SECURITY GUARDS.
CLEAN PART TIME SECURITY GUARDS
RECEIVE BASIC SCHOOL SAFETY
TRAINING CURRENT LAW LIMITS THE
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS SECURITY
PERSONNEL.
WORK MORE THAN TWENTY HOURS AND
OF COURSE -- IF SOMETHING
HAPPENS TYPICALLY THE ASSAILANT
IS NOT GOING TO INQUIRE AS TO
WHETHER THE SECURITY GUARDS.
ARE PART TIME OR FULL TIME SO.
THE NUMBER OF PART TIME
POSITIONS HAS INCREASED IN
RECENT YEARS -- S. HAS ATTENTION
TO THE SCHOOL CLIMATE.
SO ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
CENTER FOR EDUCATION STATISTICS
IN. TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN FIVE
POINT 2% OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
REPORTED BEING THREATENED OR
BULLIED WITH THE WEAPON WHILE ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES THAT'S A
FRIGHTENING FIGURE -- DURING THE
SAME YEAR OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS REMOVED FROM
CAMPUS AFTER BEING INVOLVED IN A
VIOLENT STUDENT INCIDENT -- SB
THREE NINETY WITH A SURE THAT.
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS AND STAFF -- THAT ALL
SCHOOL SECURITY GUARDS ARE
PROPERLY TRAINED. TO DEAL WITH
ISSUES -- CONCERNING SCHOOL
SAFETY I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
US [inaudible]
YES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CENTER PRAYER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AS SENATOR
UMBERG INDICATED SB THREE NINETY
ENSURES THAT ALL SECURITY GUARDS.
ARE TRAINED ON BASIC SCHOOL
SAFETY PRINCIPLES [inaudible]
LONG.
AND THE FIRST.
ONE AFTER. EIGHT WHEN THE
INITIAL TRAINING A REQUIREMENT
WAS PASSED -- THERE HAVE BEEN A
SEVENTY NINE INSTANCES OF GUN
VIOLENCE ON SCHOOL CAMPUSES SB
THREE NINETY ENSURES THAT ALL
SCHOOL SECURITY GUARDS
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY HOURS
THEY WORK A WEEK ARE TRAINED TO
RESPOND TO THESE EMERGENCIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
DONNA ARE TWO CABBAGE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERS MEGAN SUPERS ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- ANY OPPOSITION --
SEEN OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS FROM ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS -- THE
MOTION WILL BE TO PASS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION.
WITH WITH THE AMOUNT IS
PROCESSED IN THAT COMMITTEE
SENATOR YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU HAVE A FIFTEEN MINUTE
CLOSE I'D LIKE TO BEGIN RIGHT
NOW -- ALL RIGHT THEN IN LIGHT
OF ASSEMBLY WOUND WEBBER'S.
COMMENT THEN I'LL AS FOR AN AYE
VOTE SO.
THANK YOU ARE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN IN HIGHER
ED O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY I'D KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL.
WELL I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I TWO US SIX VOTES SO IT
IS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU CENTER.
THANK YOU I WOULD THAT WE WANT
TO SENATOR BATES SWITCHES -- I
AM TEN SB.
FIVE FIVE FOUR ONE GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU ADJOURNMENT
IN MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
2% ARE HERE TODAY SENATE BILL.
FIVE FORTY ONE I JOINTLY
AUTHORED WITH SENATOR PORTANTINO
AS AMENDED THE BILL REQUIRES ALL
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH TWELFTH
GRADE PUBLIC PRIVATE AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS WITH ENROLLMENT OF FIFTY
OR MORE STUDENTS TO CONDUCT ONE
LOCKDOWN DRILL OR MULTI OPTION
RESPONSE DRILL PER SCHOOL YEAR.
EXISTING EDUCATION CODE REQUIRES
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS TO CONDUCT
FIRE DRILLS REGULARLY IN
INTERMEDIATE LEVEL AND SECONDARY
SCHOOLS AT LEAST TWICE A YEAR.
HOWEVER EXISTING STATUTE DOES
NOT REQUIRE TRAINING FOR ANY
OTHER TYPES OF THREATS THAT MAY
OCCUR ON A CAMPUS THAT MAY
JEOPARDIZE THE SAFETY OF ALL ON
CAMPUS.
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE TAKEN
IT UPON THEMSELVES TO PROVIDE
THIS TRAINING BUT IS CRITICAL
FOR ALL OF OUR SCHOOLS AND
CHILDREN SHOULD BE PREPARED.
FOR EVERY SITUATION LAST YEAR WE
DID HAVE TREMENDOUS STRIDES ARE
MADE HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADDRESS SCHOOL SAFETY BUT
MEASURES LACKED A REQUIREMENTTO
CONDUCT THE LOCKDOWN DRILL SO I
AUTHORED SB TWELVE OH THREE AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT DID PASS
THIS COMMITTEE ON THE SENATE
FLOOR UNANIMOUSLY.
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I. S. B. FIVE FORTY ONE IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS ARE MEETING A BASIC
STANDARD YOU HAVE ANNUAL WALK
DOWN TRAININGS ON SIDE IN ORDER
TO BE PREPARED AND WITH ME TODAY
A SERGEANT DERREN.
BROWN WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE AND HE WILL
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND ANSWER
ANY OUR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE [inaudible]
WEBER C..
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I AM PLEASED
TODAY TO REPRESENT ORANGE
CANCERS DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FORTY ONE WHICH REQUIRES
ONE LOCKDOWN DRILL PER YEAR IN
ALL KEY THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS.
WITH FIFTY STUDENTS ARE MORE IN
MY CAPACITY AS A SERGEANT WITH
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I
OVERSEE THE SCHOOL MOBILE
ASSESSMENT AND RESOURCE TEAM
ALSO KNOWN AS SMART.
THIS UNIT RESPONSE ALL INCIDENTS
RELATED TO VIOLENCE THREATS OF
VIOLENCE POSSESSION AND OR USE
OF WEAPONS UNSTABLE BEHAVIORS
AND SORT OF SUICIDAL ACTIONS ARE
TENDENCIES THAT POSE A THREAT TO
OTHERS AT K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS.
ORANGE CANCERS JURISDICTION.
INCLUDES A LARGE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF CAPISTRANO IN
SADDLEBACK VALLEY IN PORTIONS OF
MANY NORTH ORANGE COUNTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
I SUPERVISE ALL OF OUR SCHOOL
RESOURCE OFFICERS AND DALY
INTERACT WITH OUR EDUCATION
PARTNERS.
THE EFFORT TO SMART AND SIMILAR
INITIATIVES HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
IN IDENTIFYING AND ELIMINATING
THREATS FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN
THROUGH TWENTY SEVENTEEN SMART
FIELDED FOUR HUNDRED SIX NINE
CALLS FOR SERVICE.
WHICH INCLUDED INVESTIGATING
THREATS AS WELL AS INVESTIGATING
REPORTS OF WEAPONS ON CAMPUS AND
OTHER ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
THE TEAM MADE A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THREE ARRESTS OVER THOSE
THREE YEARS AND HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN OF THOSE STUDENTS
WERE MANDATED TO PARTICIPATE IN
ARGUED DIVERSION PROGRAM.
EVEN WITH THE BEST OF EFFORTS
AND SYSTEMS IN PLACE WE MUST
ALWAYS BE PREPARED FOR THE WORST
POSSIBILITY.
PREPARATION MEANS PRACTICE
STUDENTS FACULTY AND PARENTS
MUST KNOW WHAT TO DO AND WHAT IT
WHAT IS EXPECTED IN THE EVENT OF
AN ACTIVE SHOOTER OR OTHER
INCIDENT OF VIOLENCE OCCURS.
REQUIRING ACTIVE THREAT DRILLS
WILL SAVE LIVES.
WE KNOW THE STRATEGY OF REQUIRED
SAFETY DRILLS WORKS IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE MANDATED
TO REQUIRE. TO DO REGULAR FIRE
DRILLS EVEN WITH THAT HEARINGS
DISTRICT FIRE CODE AND THE USE
OF FIRE SPRINKLERS SCHOOL FIRES
CAN OCCUR.
DEATH AS A RESULT THE SCHOOL
FIRES HOWEVER ARE RARE.
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS ARE WELL
VERSED IN WHAT TO DO DURING A
FIRE AND KNOW HOW TO SAFELY
EVACUATE BECAUSE THEY PRACTICE.
SIMILARLY WE MUST ENSURE
PRACTICES OCCURRING WITH REGARD
TO ACTIVE THREATS.
AS WE ANALYZE A TRAGIC SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS OR LAST FEW YEARS ONE
FOURTH MAN IS ABLE TO IDENTIFY
COMMON THREADS IN TACTICS USED
BY THE SHOOTERS.
AS A RESULT WE ARE ABLE TO
DETERMINE THE BEST SAFETY
STRATEGIES THAT SHOULD BE
EMPLOYED IN ORDER TO ELIMINATE
OR REDUCE FATALITIES IF A
SHOOTING INCIDENT OR THREAT
OCCURRED IN ONE OF OUR LOCAL
CAMPUSES.
THE BEST STRATEGIES HOWEVER ARE%
USELESS UNLESS THE BROADER
SCHOOL COMMUNITY KNOWS WHAT TO
DO AND WHEN WHEN THEY ARE IN
DANGER.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY'S ONE HIDE FIGHT
PROGRAM IS ONE SUCH SUCH EXAMPLE
OF THE USABLE STRATEGY IS
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS ARE NOT
AWARE OF WHAT TO DO HOWEVER THE
STRATEGIES MEANING LESS.
THE LEGISLATURE BEFORE
LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
AN EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE THE CODIFYING RECOGNIZE
BACK BEST PRACTICE INTO LAW.
SUCH A REQUIREMENT WILL ENSURE
THAT OUR SCHOOLS DEDICATE TIME
AT LEAST ONCE PER YEAR TO
PREPARE FOR A MOMENT IN TIME
WHICH WE HOPE WILL NEVER OCCUR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
TODAY THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
FOR US HERE ON BEHALF OF CITY OF
LOS ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU A SENIOR THERE'S A
SUPPORT ANY ANY OPPOSITION.
SOON OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT
BACK.
ANY COMMENTS READY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS -- SING -- NINE CENTER
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL BUT I'VE
BEEN IN MANY A LOCKDOWN IN A
MANY LOCKDOWN TRAININGS AS WELL --
ONE OF MY LOCKDOWNS ABOUT SIX
HOURS SO THEY CAN AND THEY CAN
BE PRETTY A PRETTY INTENSE --
BUT I I I AGREE THAT.
THIS NEEDS TO BE A REGULAR
OCCURRENCE SO -- THANK YOU FOR
YOUR BILL WITH THAT -- WE HAVE A
MOTION.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST YEAR
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL.
OUR O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I VOEPEL [inaudible]
I WEBER [inaudible]
UBER I SIX WAS THE BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU CENTER.
THEY WERE THAT WERE WAITING FOR
SENATOR RUBIO AND SENATOR ROTH.
WHEN WE TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR NOW [inaudible]
WHICH IS [inaudible]
SHE RESEMBLES [inaudible]
JUST.
SURE YOUR FIRST.
VISIT.
ONE DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
BY DOCTOR MA'AM WEBER A SECOND
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH -- THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OR THE FILE
ITEM ONE AC ARE.
EIGHTY SEVEN BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
FILE ITEM TO SB ONE THIRTY EIGHT
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS FILE
ITEM SIX SB.
THREE FORTY SIX THE PASTOR.
FILE ITEM NINE SB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT TO PASS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
FILE ITEMS [inaudible] THIRTEEN
S. C. R. SIX BE ADOPTED TO
APPROPRIATIONS [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I'D.
MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I VOEPEL [inaudible]
I WEBER [inaudible]
UBER I'D. SIX VOTES THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT WITH THAT AGAIN
WE'RE WAITING FOR SENATORS ROBIN
RUBIO -- AND I WOULD CALL YOUR
OFFICES SO IF YOU'RE LISTENING.
OR WAITING.
BUT WE WON'T WAY FOREVER.
THANK YOU TO ADD ONS NOW.
WE OUGHT TO TAKE A TIME AND
SENATOR HERTZBERG STYLE AND THEN
AGAIN WHO ACTUALLY DID LET'S GO
BACK TO SENATOR HERTZBERG BILL
[inaudible]
WHICH IS. FOR FILE ITEM.
FOR SB TWO SIXTY FIVE IS OUR
MOTION.
THEN MOVED AND MISTER KERR
SECONDS.
MOVED AND SECONDED.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST YOU
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY SMITH.
SMITH I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WEBER.
WEBER I YEAH [inaudible]
YOUR AVAILABLE [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO WHEN WE MOVED TO ADD ON'S.
THE SECRETARY WILL.
FILE ITEM THREE SB.
TWO TWENTY THREE MISSION IS TO
PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
THE CHAIR VOTING AYE KALRA.
KALRA EYES MCCARTY [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTED
IS OUT -- THE FILE ITEM TWELVE
SB SIX EIGHTY SIX THE MOTION IS
THE PASTOR PREPARATIONS WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY WEBER.
WEBER I ABOUT.
US FOR VOTED IS OUT.
THE CONSTRUCTION FIRM WHICH IS
WHAT.
WHAT WAS HER A? THREE SIXTEEN
OKAY WHAT IS A FIREMAN OR FIVE
SB THREE SIXTEEN SENATOR RUBIO
YOU MAY COME FORWARD AND PRESENT.
FILE UNDER.
FIVE THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
HERE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT SB
THREE ONE SIX AN IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT WILL BENEFIT
OUR STUDENTS.
SB THREE SIXTEEN ALLOWS PRIVATE
AND PUBLIC EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS. TO PRINT THE
TELEPHONE NUMBER OF THE NATIONAL
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOTLINE ON THE
BACK OF THE STUDENT ID CARDS OUR
STUDENTS ARE BEING VICTIMIZED
[inaudible]
CHRISTINE.
NUMBER OF ABUSE IN TEENAGE
RELATIONSHIPS.
THE CDC REPORTS THAT EVERY YEAR
ONE IN FOR IT ADOLESCENCE CLAIMS
TO HAVE SUFFER FROM A TYPE OF
ABUSE.
BY A DATING PARTNER.
TEENAGE SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SUFFER LASTING
CONSEQUENCES FROM THE ABUSE THEY
OFTEN MISS SCHOOL.
DROP OUT IN OUR GREAT RISK OF
BECOMING DEPRESSED SUICIDAL OR
ENGAGING IN RISKY SEXUAL
BEHAVIOR.
WE NEED TO BE VIGILANT AND OFFER
SUPPORT.
HERE WITH ME IS LIZABETH ASK
ABOUT WHO WILL LIKE TO OFFER HER
TESTIMONY ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE THANK YOU [inaudible]
HI.
CHAIR MEMBERS ELIZABETH ASK
ABOUT CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS I JUST
WANTED -- TO NOTE THAT WE
ORIGINALLY HAD A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL
WE'RE ASKING FOR ADDITIONAL TIME
TO IMPLEMENT THIS AS JUNIOR HIGH
AND A FRESHMAN AND NEW STUDENT
ORIENTATIONS TEND TO HAPPEN IN
JULY AND AUGUST SO WE APPRECIATE
AUTHORS OFFICE BEING
ACCOMMODATING TO THAT CONCERN.
OUT SB THREE SIXTEEN REQUIRES
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS TO PRINT TELEPHONE
NUMBERS FOR THE DOMESTIC.
VIOLENCE HOTLINE ON THE BACK OF
THE SENATE ID CARDS THIS BILL IS
NEEDED BECAUSE OUR ADOLESCENT
AND YOUTH ARE EXPERIENCING AN
INCREASING ANNA.
INCREASE IN A HEALTHY AND
ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIPS WE KNOW
THAT THESE EXPERIENCES CAN HAVE
A LASTING IMPRESSION ON STUDENTS
AND FOR THESE REASONS STUDENTS
NEED AND QUICK ACCESS TO THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PHONE NUMBER.
AND BEING ABLE TO TURN TO THE
BACK OF THE ID CARD IS THAT
SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY CAN TURN
FOR HELP.
ANOTHER THING THAT I LIKE TO
LEAVE YOU WITH IS THAT ONE OF
OUR MEMBERS SPECIFICALLY SAID WE
KNOW SCHOOL DISTRICTS ALREADY
CURRENTLY PUTTING THESE NUMBERS
ON THE BACK OF THE ID CARDS.
AND ONE OF OUR MEMBERS SAID YOU
KNOW WE PUT THEM ON THE ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS IDEAS BECAUSE YOU
JUST NEVER KNOW WHO IN THE HOME
IT'S GOING TO NEED THIS PHONE
NUMBER.
AND SO FOR THESE REASONS I
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON MEMBER
SHIRLEY DEATH CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
VERSUS YUSHIN SUPPORT.
SEEING NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
COMPORT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME DRAPER NOW I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION FOR
THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS IF IT'S A PUBLIC POLICY VOICE
OF THE CHURCH IN THE STATE WE
OPPOSE SB.
THREE SIXTEEN OUR OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL IS VERY SPECIFIC.
THE INCLUSION OF ANY MORE
NUMBERS OF OTHER HOTLINES
REGARDLESS HOW WORTHY WILL
DIMINISH EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
ONLY NUMBER THAT'S NOW REQUIRED.
I'M STOOD IDENTIFICATION CARDS
THE NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE.
NOT EVERY IMPORTANT ASSISTANCE
NUMBER CAN FIT ON A STUDENT ID.
WITH EACH ADDITIONAL NUMBER
REQUIRED AND STUDENT ID IS ALL
BECOME SMALLER.
AND AT SOME POINT THEY CAN
BECOME USELESS.
SUICIDE AMONG OUR TEENS AND
COLLEGE STUDENTS IS UNPARALLELED
NATIONAL CRISIS.
ADDITIONAL NUMBERS BEING PLACED
ON THEIR PUTS THAT AT RISK YES
FROM SUICIDE AMONG CHILDREN
YOUNGER THAN SEVENTEEN YEARS OF
AGE.
HAVE GROWN 84% IN THE LAST
DECADE.
AND INCREASED 210031% AMONG
GIRLS AGES.
TEN TO FOURTEEN SUICIDE IS NOW
THE SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF
DEATH FOR THOSE AGES.
TEN TO TWENTY FOUR NEARLY ONE IN
FIVE CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS HAVE SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERED ATTEMPTING SUICIDE.
9% HAVE ATTEMPTED SUICIDE ONE OR
MORE TIMES.
EVERY LIFE IS PRECIOUS AND MUST
BE PROTECTED ESPECIALLY WHEN
THEY ARE WEAK AND VULNERABLE.
HAVING ONLY THE NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION LIFELINE ON ID'S
HELPS PREVENT IMMINENT DEATH
AMONG OUR YOUTH WHO ARE AT RISK
OF KILLING THEMSELVES.
THAT'S WHY THE SINGLE NUMBER WAS
PLACED ON STUDENT ID'S WITH
UNANIMOUS APPROVAL OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND WITH THE
UNIVERSAL SUPPORT.
AMONG CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SCHOOL COMMUNITIES ALIKE.
THIS ONE NUMBER GIVE STUDENTS
CONTEMPLATING SUICIDE.
IN OTHER STUDENTS WHO KNOW
CLASSMATES THAT MAY BE DOING SO.
A DEDICATED RESOURCE TO
IMMEDIATELY ACCESS CRITICAL
SUPPORT IN MOMENTS OF CRISIS.
SB THREE SIXTEEN WOULD DETRACT
FROM THIS VITAL RESOURCE.
IT'S FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
RECOMMEND AND REQUEST THAT YOU
VOTE NO ON SENATE BILL.
THREE SIXTY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK -- TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ARE JUST
BECOMING AYE AYE ACTUALLY I
THINK YOU TO RAISE A GOOD POINT.
THAT THE LONGER LIST GROWS AND
WE DO GET A LITTLE CONCERNED
THAT.
YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO RECREATE
THE PHONE BOOK HERE AND THE KIDS
GOING TO WALK AROUND THE PHONE
BOOK.
SO I JUST THINK CERTAINLY GOING
FOR I'M VERY SUPPORT OF THIS
TODAY BUT I THINK CERTAINLY
GOING FORWARD WE NEED TO BE BE
CAREFUL.
ABOUT WHAT WE ADD. TO THAT LIST
OTHER ALL IMPORTANT DON'T GET ME
WRONG I I CAN SEE THAT OUT OF
THE GATE WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THEY REMAIN IMPORTANT.
AND THAT SOMEHOW THE FUN DOESN'T
GET SMALLER SMALLER AND SMALLER
IN THE CAR DOESN'T MEAN MUCH TO
STUDENTS SO THAT.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS MANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SAYING AND WE HAVE A MOTION.
I JUST WANT TO ASK A QUESTION I
KNOW THIS ISSUE WAS RAISED IN
THE OTHER COMMITTEE HAVE YOU
HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THAT IS A A MAJOR
CONCERN THAT.
I CAN THINK OF AT LEAST FOUR
FIVE OF THE FOLKS ONE AT NUMBERS
TO THE BACK OF THE CARD SO.
HAVE YOU GIVEN THAT MUCHTHOUGHT
AS TO HOW IT SHOULD BE DONE OR
YOU KNOW I WAS WONDERING IF
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT LIKE
THERE'S A TWO ONE ONE NUMBER
THAT THEY AND FEEDS OUT.
TO IN MANY CITIES TO OTHERS
SUPPORT SERVICES SO YOU DON'T
END UP WITH.
EVERYBODY WITH THE NUMBER ON THE
BACK OF THE STUDENT ID CARD.
WELL I HAVE GIVEN IT MUCH TO
THOUGHT AND THEN OF COURSE I'VE
I RECOGNIZE ALL THE FACT THAT HE
JUST OFFERED AS IT PERTAINS --
TO TEENAGE SUICIDE IT WAS AN
EDUCATOR FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS AND
BELIEVE ME I HAVE SEEN IT ALL.
BUT I WOULD ARGUE THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IS A SILENT KILLER I'VE
SEEN.
TEENAGE GIRLS GET INTO THESE
RELATIONSHIPS WHERE THEY CAN GET
OUT AND I WOULD SPEAK FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS YOU ALL
KNOW I'M A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
AND COMING FROM A VERY CATHOLIC
HOUSEHOLD THESE ARE ISSUES THAT
WERE NOT ALLOWED TO DISCUSS IN
MY HOUSEHOLD.
SO FOR ME WHEN I THINK OF MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE HAVING HAD
SOMETHING.
AT AND MY HANDS TO TO REACH OUT --
TO FOR SUPPORT WOULD HAVE BEEN.
HELPFUL HAD I NEEDED IT AT THE
TIME BUT AS IT PERTAINS TO WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO NUMBERS
ON A CARD -- DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
MUCH I CAN I CAN SEE YOUR
CONCERN ABOUT FUTURE ADDING TO
THIS CARD BUT TWO NUMBERS TO ME --
IF IT HELPS SAVE A YOUNG LADY.
FROM FALLING VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE I THINK IT'S IT'S
DETRIMENTAL I MEAN I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE IT THERE AND I HAVE
CONSIDERED I JUST THINK THAT
THAT WOULD BE UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE THEY CONTINUED OUT
NUMBERS BUT RIGHT NOW TO NUMBERS.
TO VERY CRITICAL NUMBER A
SUICIDE AS I'VE SEEN THAT ALSO
MY SCHOOLS AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
TEENAGE DATING VIOLENCE IS ALSO
IMPORTANT SO.
I AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
BUT THAT WOULD BE UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE THEY WANT TO KEEP
THAT AND I THINK THOSE TWO
NUMBERS VISUALLY ARE PERFECT AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
I'VE HEARD PEOPLE ASK ABOUT SEX
TRAFFICKING AS WELL IN TERMS OF
A NUMBER FOR THAT -- AND AND I
KNOW THAT'S A MAJOR ISSUE IN
CHALLENGE -- IN LOTS OF SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES THAT THERE AND
AND JUST IS EQUALLY AS DANGEROUS
IN TERMS OF THE DAMAGE YOU CAN
DO TO YOUNG PEOPLE SO.
YOU KNOW I I'VE I'VE HEARD FOLKS
ASK AND SO I I I I'M SUPPORTIVE
OF THIS BUT I AM CONCERNED.
AND I THINK AS THE LEGISLATURE
AT SOME POINT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT -- WITH
REGARDS TO WHAT REALLY GOES ON
THE BACK OF THOSE CARS OR BETTER
WAY OF DEALING WITH IT OR
SOMETHING I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER BUT I AM
CONCERNED BECAUSE I DO WANT --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
NUMBERS WE PUT ON THERE REALLY
ARE FUNCTIONAL AND SO WE DON'T
HAVE SO MANY THAT.
THEY BECOME MEANINGLESS IN TERMS
OF EITHER THE SIZE OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF FOLKS USING IT I
THINK THAT'S THE CONCERN I
EXPRESS.
WE'VE GOT THIS.
BUT ONE WAY ONE LAST YEAR NOW WE
HAVE A PRETTY WE HAVE ANOTHER
BILL WORKING THROUGH
LEGISLATURE'S TWO RIGHT AND NEXT
YEAR THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO
TWITTER ON THEIR AND EVERYTHING
ELSE PROBABLY RIGHT.
SO -- THAT I THINK IS A REAL
CONCERN YEAH BUT BUT WE WERE
PREPARED JUST TO SUPPORT THIS
TODAY I DON'T ANY WE NEED TO
BELABOR THE POINT.
BECAUSE REALLY IT'S NOT ABOUT
YOU.
YOUR EFFORT IT'S ABOUT NEXT YEAR
THERE'S GONNA BE TEN MORE BILLS.
I QUE ITEM.
THAT'S MY PREDICTION AND ONE AT
TEN OTHER THINGS ADDED ON THERE
AND IT'S NOT THAT THEY'RE NOT
IMPORTANT.
ISSUES HOW DO WE MAKE THIS
EFFECTIVE HOW DO WE MAKE IT WORK
FOR SCHOOLS AND I CAN ISSUE A
AGAIN ENSURE THAT STUDENTS TO
CARRY AROUND PHONE BOOK ALL DAY.
WHAT THIS BODY IS DONE SO IF I
MAY -- MISTER DONALD I I
UNDERSTAND BUT YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES THESE CARDS ARE ALMOST
USELESS YOU KNOW KIDS CARRY THEM
AROUND AND AND WHICH IS VISUALLY
IT'S THERE FOR THEM TO JUST.
LIKE AT ALL YEAR LONG AND IF IT
COULD BE JUST A RESOURCE YOU
KNOW -- YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
YOUR CONCERN BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE THOSE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN.
GREAT ANY OTHER BECAUSE MANY OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBER SEE NO
COMMENTS -- YOU MAY DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
MOVED AND DID DOCTOR WEBER
SECOND NOW I DON'T REMEMBER I
QUE AND THOUGH IT'S OCTOBER
SECOND -- MOVED AND SECONDED --
THE MOTION WILL BE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YAK WITH
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL AYE
O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I'M MCCARTY STE BUT
MCCARTY AYE SMITH.
SMITH I VOEPEL.
I WEBER HI WEBER I THE BILL HAS
SEVEN VOTED IS OUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SIX AVAILABLE THOUSAND K..
OKAY OUR GONNA MOVE TO OUR LAST
BILL BY SENATOR ROTH -- WHAT A
PHONE NUMBER WE ARE HERE?
HELLO FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB. FIVE
FIVE FOR SANITY MAY PROCEED WHEN
READY.
HE WAS CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS
BILL INTENDS ON PROVIDING AN
ADULT HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT WITH
THE SAME BENEFIT AFFORDED TO
MINOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO
WISH TO AND DOING ROLE IN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AS YOU KNOW RESEARCH BOTH
NATIONALLY AND IN CALIFORNIA'S
DOCUMENTED THAT -- DOING ROMAN
IS A POWERFUL STRATEGY FOR
INCREASING COLLEGE SUCCESS IN
AFFORDABILITY FOR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
THE BILL SIMPLY PROVIDES A
STREAMLINED APPROACH FOR ADULT
HIGH SCHOOL EQUIVALENCY STUDENTS
TO CONCURRENTLY IN ROLE.
IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE BY
SIMPLIFYING THE ENROLLMENT
PROCESS AND IN SOME CASES WAVING
TUITION AND FEES BASICALLY
SPECIAL ADMITS. TO PROVIDE
GREATER CLARITY I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES THAT -- WE ARE HERE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND PROVIDE
BRIEF TESTIMONY BRAND RUNS
DIRECTOR OF POLICY AND ADVOCACY.
CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION AND
DOCTOR MATTHEW MORIN DIRECTOR
DISTANCE EDUCATION.
ADULT EDUCATION AND HIGH SCHOOL
PARTNERSHIPS THAT CHEEKY COLLEGE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
O'DONNELL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
ORIGINAL SCAN CONDUCTED BY
CHAFEE COLLEGE AND THE ADULT
SCHOOLS OF THE WEST AND CORD OR
ADULT EDUCATION CONSORTIUM FOUND.
THAT BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ONLY TWO HUNDRED AND
NINE OUT OF THE SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND THREE
ADULTS SCHOOL ENROLLEES IN THE
CHAFEE COLLEGE.
DISTRICT AND ROLLED IN THE
CHAFEE COLLEGE CREDIT COURSE.
TRAGICALLY IN THIS GROUP THE
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL
EQUIVALENCY IN HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA STUDENTS WHO TRANSITION
SUCCESSFULLY TO JP COLLEGE.
WERE BELOW 1%.
THIS PAINTED A DARK PICTURE OF
TROUT COLLEGE TRANSITION FOR
THOSE IN OUR COMMUNITY WHO ARE
MOST LIKELY TO REMAIN IN POVERTY.
WITHOUT HIGHER EDUCATION
ATTAINMENT.
IN FALL TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
ATTEMPTING TO IMPROVE THIS
CRISIS OF TRANSITION CHAFEE
COLLEGE AND THE ADULT SCHOOLS IN
ITS SERVICE DISTRICT EMBARKED ON
A RADICAL STRATEGY.
CO LOCATING CREDIT BEARING C. T.
E. AND COLLEGE TRANSITION
CLASSES AT THE ADULT SCHOOLS.
AFTER ONE SEMESTER THE ADULT
SCHOOL STAFF EXPRESS THAT MANY
HIGH SCHOOL EQUIVALENCY AND HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA STUDENTS WERE NOT
ENROLLING IN THE CLASSES.
BECAUSE THEY WERE INTIMIDATED BY
THE PERSONAL IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION REQUIRED TO ENROLL
SUCH AS INCOME VERIFICATION.
AND CALIFORNIA RESIDENCY
DOCUMENTATION.
IN CALIFORNIA THE SPECIAL PART
TIME ADMIN ROMAN STATUS IS A
TOOL THAT COLLEGES USED TO
ENROLL HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WITHOUT REQUIRING THEM TO
COMPLETE FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS INCOME VERIFICATION
AND RESIDENCY INFORMATION.
IN SPRING TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
CHAFEE COLLEGE CREATED A
STRUCTURE DUAL ENROLLMENT
PROGRAM FOR ADULT HSE AND HSE
STUDENTS.
USING THE SPECIAL PART TIME
ADMIT ENROLLMENT PROCESS TO
OVERCOME THE BARRIERS OF THE
PREVIOUS SEMESTERS CHALLENGES.
THE PROGRAM SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASED ENROLLMENT FROM THESE
POPULATIONS IT WAS ADORED BY THE
ADULT SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS AND
RECEIVE TREMENDOUS INTEREST FROM
OTHER COLLEGE AS AN ADULT
SCHOOLS.
AFTER THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
NOTIFIED CHIEF THE COLLEGE THAT
ADULT SCHOOL STUDENTS WERE NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR SPECIAL PART TIME
ENROLLMENT.
THE COLLEGE HALTED ITS CREDIT
BEARING DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAM.
SB FIVE FIVE FOUR WILL MAKE A
PATHWAY POSSIBLE TO RESTART THIS
IMPORTANT WORK AT CHAFEE AND AT
OTHER COLLEGES.
IT WILL CREATE A POWERFUL TOOL
WITH WHICH TO REACH THE
POPULATION THAT THE ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN ONLINE COLLEGE IS
FUNDED TO TARGET.
BUT AT NO ADDITIONAL COST BY THE
STATE.
FINALLY SB FIVE FIVE FOUR WILL
MAKE CALIFORNIA AND INNOVATIVE
LEADER IN PROVIDING THE
EQUITABLE EXPANSION OF DUAL
ENROLLMENT. TO INCLUDE ADULT
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AN
UNPRECEDENTED BUT COMMON THANK
YOU CONCEPT GOOD JOB.
YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
ACTUALLY I AM VERY OUT OF
FRIENDS DOCTOR POLICY NOT
BECAUSE HE PUT ADDS COALITION B.
AS COALITION IS A NONPARTISAN
COALITION OF BUSINESS LABOR
EDUCATION WORK FORCE AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS.
WE ARE THE PROUD SPONSORS OF THE
SPELLING RESPECTFULLY OR DRIVE
OUT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEVEN ASH ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SUPPORT.
MAYBE RODRIGUEZ ALL WE HAVE THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST IN SUPPORT.
OKAY SHILOH LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NASA MEN ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY AND CONTINUING
EDUCATION.
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND MOUNT SAN
ANTONIO COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
THE TERM MEMBERS CHRISTIE B<c.cyan></c>
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OPPOSITION -- SEEN
OPPOSITION WILL BRING BACK
BEHIND THE RAIL -- ALL JUST
COMIC QUICKLY CENTER THANK YOU
FOR THE BILL IT'S ABOUT WHAT I
LIKE ABOUT BILLS LIKE THIS IS
THE CREATE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITY.
RATHER THAN JUST TELLING PEOPLE
WHAT TO DO.
WE ACTUALLY CREATES OPPORTUNITY
I THINK THAT'S A GREAT THING.
SO I APPRECIATE YOUR APPROACH
AND HELPING FACILITATE SUCCESS.
BY KIND OF UNLOCKING.
DOORS RATHER LOCKING THEM DOWN I
WITH THAT -- ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WHICH SPEAK SING AND WE
HAVE A MOTION.
BEEN MOVED AND SECOND SECOND BY
DOCTOR WEBER -- YOU MAY CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THE MOTION IS THE PASTOR HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE O'DONNELL.
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE KALRA.
KALRA I'D MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE SMITH SMITH I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I'VE.
ROOM SEVEN SEVEN ALSO RESULT
CENTER THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT OF MEMBERS -- COULD
JUST STAY SEATED FOR A MOMENT WE
WILL HAVE A BELIEVE THE ROLE OF
ROUNDS MEMBERS IF YOU WISH.
TO ADD ON ANY BILL PLEDGES
PLEASE STAY IN YOUR SEAT AND
WE'LL GET IT DONE HERE.
THE COMMITTEE SECRETARY WILL
CALL THE ROLL IN EACH.
OF THOSE ITEMS.
CAN I AM CAN I DROP THE GAL.
YOU CAN INJURE EVERYTHING'S ON
WHAT.
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
CONSENT [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
CARTY I'VE.
ROOM.
FILE ITEM THREE SB TWO TWENTY
THREE THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I'VE.
FILE ITEM FOR SB TWO SIXTY FIVE
THE CHAIR VOTING I'D MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I'VE.
FILE ITEM SEVEN SB THREE NINETY
THE CHAIR VOTING I'D MCCARTY
[inaudible]
THE I..
FILE ITEM EIGHT SB FOUR TWENTY
EIGHT THE CHAIR VOTING ICE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I FILE ITEM TEN SB FIVE
FORTY ONE THE CHAIR VOTING I
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY AYE [inaudible]
FILE ITEM. TWELVE SB SIX EIGHTY
SIX THE CHAIR VOTING I MCCARTY
[inaudible]
MCCARTY I THEY WERE VERY WELL
MAYBE
[inaudible]
THE